こんにちははじめしゃちょーです皆さんは
合唱したことありますでしょうか多分学生
のほとんどの人は経験したことあるんです
けども俺も中学校とか高校の時学生の時に
合唱コンクールというのがあってこう
みんなで協力して歌を歌うっていうのが
あったんですけども結構好きでして結構
合唱コンクールとかその歌うの実は下手
なりに好きで
合唱に欠かせないものそうハモリです
ハモリパート分けされるんですよこういう
の低い人は手なら恋の硬い人はソプラノ
あるとテナーってこうハモってめっちゃ
おしゃれめっちゃいい感じになって合唱
ってそのハモリっていうのがあるとそこで
そこで皆さんバナナサンドっていう番組で
ハモリ我慢選手権っていうのがあってどう
いうものかというと普通に歌う人がいて
周りに合唱団がいてで合唱団の人たちが
サビの部分だけ
めっちゃくちゃ普通に歌えないぐらい
異常にハモってきてハモリ我慢できる
かっていうのがあってそれめちゃくちゃ
冷たくてですね今回ハモリ我慢できるよう
な状況を準備しましたそして今回なんと
ですねこの企画のためにわざわざアメリカ
から来てくださいました米国を新刊させた
超大物オーケストラ歌手の方ですどうぞ
[拍手]
すげえどうも
胎児の頃から絶対音感
モーツァルトバッハベートーヴェンです
ありがとうございますこの企画のために
アメリカから来てくださったってそうです
ねすごいですねアメリカのどこらへんにお
住まいなんですか
僕だけだと成功できるかわかんないんです
一般の
そうだった
しっかりしてください僕だけだと分かん
ないからちょっと他の人も使ってゲーム
やってみたいと思いますではいきましょう
[音楽]
はいというわけで今日はですねプロの
コーラス団体のウキウキプロジェクトさん
とトレビーさんに
協力していただいておりますありがとう
ございますというわけでサビまでは一緒に
合唱を歌ってサビで突然
めちゃくちゃハモリが強い感じで歌って
いただきます
果たして引っ張られずに歌いきることが
できるんでしょうか一応3曲チャレンジ
できるようにはしてやりますでは最初の曲
ですよろしくお願いします
[音楽]
私は私と
はぐれるわけないから
会いましょうその日まで最大の恋心よ
[音楽]
[拍手]
嘘をつくくらいなら何を知ってくれなくて
いいあなたはさておきこっそりだけは
分かっているから見つかって私は
可愛い女の子じゃなかったね全て最後は
笑顔で語らせて
涙が悲しみを溶かして
溢れるものだとしたらその
雫のもう一度してしまいた
続ける限りあなたを忘れずにいられる
でしょう
許してね
恋心
[音楽]
めっちゃ引っ張られましたわ声が良すぎる
バツバツに引っ張られちゃったこれ
ちょっともう1人
天才音楽家の方も出るのでその引き方に
挑戦してもらいたいと思います
[音楽]
[拍手]
じゃあよろしくお願いします
[音楽]
私は私とそうつくくらいなら何も話して
くれなくて
あなたの去って行くのそれだけはわかっ
てるからその日まで
恋心
[音楽]
いいんじゃないですかもう一回やってみて
もいいですかお願いします
[音楽]
私は私と
はぐれるわけに
はいないから
会いましょう
届けまでさようなら
恋心よ
嘘をつくぐらいなら何も話してくれなくて
いいあなたはテクノそれだけは分かって
いるから見つめ合った私は
可愛い女じゃなかったねせめて最後は笑顔
で語らせて
涙
がどかして
溢れるものとしたらその
雫のもう一度飲み干してしまいたい痛み
ブレーキとどまり続ける
あなたを忘れずにいられるでしょう
恋をとろうよ
甘い夢は
波にさらわれたのいつかまた
逢いましょうその日までさいなる恋心よ
行けました多分
言ってました
2回目とかはちょっと学習しちゃってなん
か行けます多分これ
[音楽]
[拍手]
風の強さがちょっと心
揺さぶりすぎて
真面目に
見つめた君が
恋しい
天狗に返しの日々
かわいそうなふりをして
[音楽]
ガラケーてみたけど
希望の光
は目の前でずっと
輝いてる
幸せだ
麦わらの
星の君がたまに乗る時に
出るあれはまだ青いのこと
懐かしいとは誰とあの日の
恋もふと
泣きそうな目で見つめる
優しさでずっとずっと
抱きしめて
離さない
[音楽]
ここでちょっとまた登場してもらい
ましょうか一番得意ですか
[音楽]
風の強さがちょっと
心を揺さぶりすぎて
真面目に
見つめた君が
恋しく
夢の前でずっと
輝いているし
合わせだ
麦わらの
星の君が揺れはい
ゴールデニーに出る青い
夏のこと
懐かしい
[拍手]
ねと泣きそうな目で見つめる君を
優しさでそっとギュッと
抱きしめて
離さない
[音楽]
大丈夫そうですかはいというわけで
ちょっと天才の歌手さんそして僕も
ちょっと
難しかったのでさらに今回さらに
スペシャルな日本を代表するシンガー
ソングライターの方に来ていただいており
ますどうぞ
[拍手]
どうもオフィシャル
髭男
サウシードッグバウンディあいみょんです
よろしくお願いしますお願いします
ありがとうございます
歌の方は結構自信はまあ人並みにはそんな
もう日本を代表するホット歌手ですか
歌えばいいんですよ
[音楽]
風の強さがちょっと
心を揺さぶりすぎて目の前でずっと
輝いているし
[音楽]
合わせだ
麦わらの
星の
[拍手]
[音楽]
ゴールドに
似てるあれは空がまだ青い
夏のこと
懐かしいと笑えたあの日の行為
でと泣きそうな目で見つめる君を雲のよう
な優しさで相当
抱きしめて
離さない
素晴らしいありがとうございます
[拍手]
どうでしたか地震のことは
みんながなんか僕につられちゃってました
ね
投げてみたけど
希望の光
は目の前でずっと
輝いてるし
[音楽]
幸せだ
麦わらの
星の木にはぐれた曲を
握ってる雨はまだ
追い出す
人は笑えたあの日の行為もう
離れないでと泣きそうな目で見つめる君を
僕のような優しさでしょうと言うと
抱きしめて
離さない
帽子の君がくれた
マリーゴールドに
似てるあれは空がまだ青い
夏のこと
懐かしいと笑えたあの日の行為もう
離れないでと泣きそうな目で
釣れる君を
雲のような優しさでずっと
[音楽]
抱きしめて
離さない
[音楽]
続いて最後の曲安藤さんの新時代よろしく
お願いします
この
未来
だ
世界
てしまえば
変えてしまう
[音楽]
さあ
魔物の屋根大人なんて決してこの世と
メタモルフォーでしょうぜYouTube
君が落とす
目を閉じれば未来が開いていつまでも
終わりが来いようにって
歌を歌うよ
[音楽]
みたいな旋律まとめない戻れない
忘れたい夢の中にさせてアルバムに見える
よ
信じてないか世界の向こう側
[音楽]
信じないはこの未来だ世界中を伝えて
しまえば
全部変えてしまえば
果てしない
孤独
のように
夢は
僕を信じて
ありがとうございますではプロの中でお
呼びしたいと思いますバッファさんお願い
します
[音楽]
信じないはこの
未来が
帰って
しまえば
しまった
認めない戻れない
忘れたいあなたにもよさせてもらえば
見えるよ
信じないが世界の向こうへ
行くよ
信じないはこの未来だ世界中全部変えて
しまえば
帰ってしまえば
[音楽]
果てしない音楽がもっと
届くように
夢は見ないわ君が話した僕僕を信じて
わけわからん
[音楽]
[拍手]
IWannaBeWith見えるよ
信じないが世界の向こうへ
は
新時代はこの未来だ世界中全部変えて
しまえば全部変えてしまえば
[音楽]
果てしない音楽がもっと
届くように
夢は見ないわそれが話した僕を信じて
綱渡りみたいな
旋律
認めない戻れない
忘れたい夢の中にさせて
IWannaBeFree見えるよ
信じないか世界の向こう
[拍手]
新時代はこの未来だ世界中全部変えて
しまえば
変えてしまえば
果てしない音楽がもっと
届くように
夢は見ないわ
君が話した僕を信じて
[音楽]
最後ちょっと2人のデュエットお願いして
もらってもいいですかね
[音楽]
じゃあもう嫌なものなんて決して世界の
向こうへ
信じないはこの未来だ世界中全部変えて
しまえば
帰ってしまえば
音楽がもっと
届くように
夢は見ないわ
話した僕を
信じて
[音楽]